être un super héros
c'est être en première ligne
qui peut protéger le monde à part des
gens comme toi et moi
[Musique]
je m'appelle jennifer walter tu avocate
j'ai des amis incroyable en faveur des
shots s'il vous plaît on a une urgence à
un travail exigeant nous venons de créer
le département des droits des super
humain et je voudrais que vous employez
la représentant une famille un peu
spécial même si on n'a rien demandé
on est obligé de faire avec des
transformations sont déclenchées par la
colère et la peur vient juste de résumer
le quotidien des femmes depuis la nuit
des temps
c'est l'impression que tout soit trois
fois par an
ouais ouais ouais non
je veux seulement être une avocate comme
toutes les autres pouvez vous nous dire
où est cette nouvelle hulk dignité
devenir un phénomène
waouh fait des fêtes incroyables
tu pourrais être un avengers roche une
super héroïne
passé pour les milliardaires et
narcissique et les orphelins peuvent
savoir pourquoi
[Musique]
rien de plus déprimant qu'être une
trentenaire célibataire
c'est mon meilleur banc car depuis
longtemps à 7/10 raid commandes et des
frites a remporté alors